weiter vielleicht das beste ergebnis für
die grünen bei der bundestagswahl
überhaupt arbeiten soziale in deutsch
oder ja wir sind das ergebnis ist
erfreulich aber wir hätten uns mehr
erwartet
und ich danke einfach erst mal unseren
wählerinnen und wählern und unserem
ganzen mal kämpferinnen in wahlkämpfen
und insbesondere sind spitzenkandidaten
annalena baerbock und 100 aber das ist
erfreulich nehme ich eben nicht ganz so
haben die grünen lagen die letzten
beiden jahre eigentlich in umfragen
konstant über 20 prozent es war ein
ergebnis war wieder schlechter als die
umfragen beziehungsweise auf die letzten
umfragen waren sie immer ungefähr auf
diesem niveau
[Applaus]
wie gesagt es ist trotz des festivals
und ich habe gesagt wir haben uns mehr
erhofft und ich glaube dass man erst mal
abwarten muss wie die zahlen am ende
wirklich ausschauen noch sind die zahlen
sehr schwankend und dann werden wir
sehen in berlin zb freuen wir uns dass
wir hoffentlich stärkste partei geworden
sind aber die zeit sagen dass die grünen
wahrscheinlich zehn prozent hinter cdu
und union liegen was ist das für ein
auftrag für eine mögliche
regierungsbildung für die grünen
es ist wir sehen das als auftrag das
beste aus dem ergebnis zu machen und
dafür zu sagen was am ende klimaschutz
rauskommt dass europa zusammengehalten
wird auch was die gesellschaft
zusammengehalten wird und die das am
ende sozusagen ausläuft glaube wird es
ein sehr langer abend durch spd und
union sind sehr eng beieinander
auf ein ehepaar und sehr nahe
beieinander liegen ist könnte er auch
darauf hindeuten dass wir möglichst weit
vorne liegen zu sondierungsgesprächen
einladen
wir haben gesagt wir schließen nichts
aus aber es lohnt sich erst mal
abzuwarten wie das ergebnis wirklich ist
aber wie sinnvoll wären parallele
gespräche mit spd und mit
jetzt erstmal für reine spekulation
schauen wir mal wer am ende vorne mit
die weit wäre denn der weg in die ampel
oder jamaika für die grünen mit diesem
ergebnis
für uns ist entscheidend dass eine
progressive regierung heraus kommt die
wirklich auf augenhöhe mit den problemen
agiert und das heißt wir müssen wirklich
jetzt dass wir sagen dass klimaschutz
abkommen einzuhalten wir wussten was wir
erlebt haben in person ab anime das
anders wir endlich eine vernünftige
digitalisierung haben wir müssen die
spaltung oder gesellschaft angehen wir
müssen europa stärken das ist das
entscheidende dass keine regierung mehr
des kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners gibt